>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT, IT'S
FRIDAY SO THAT MEANS NOTABLE
QUOTABLE'S.
>> HOPEFULLY DEMOCRATS WILL STOP
PLAYING GAMES.
>> THEY'VE BEEN ON THE SIDELINES
PLAYING POLITICS FROM DAY ONE.
>> HE CREATED THIS CRISIS.
>> EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY, WE ARE
ESTABLISHING A NEW BORDER
SECURITY PORT.
>> I TOLD MEXICO --
>> WE'RE FOCUSING ON OUR
CANADIAN FRIENDS.
>> THE STORES ARE ALL GONE.
>> I'M NOT PREPARED TO SAY IT'S
A WAY FOR MISHAPS OR SOME FORM
OF CRISIS.
>> POLICE, NOT SLOWLY, BUT
STARTED COMMENTING.
>> IT RIGHT NOW, PRUITT IS A MAN
IN WASHINGTON.
>> THIS WAS LIKE AN AIRBNB
SITUATION.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BLOW UP
WASHINGTON AND REINVENTED.
>> THIS IS NOT FOR REVENGE.
>> MY OPPONENT, HE TALKS ABOUT
TRUMP, BUT WHEN IT'S TIME TO
SHOW COURAGE AND VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S AGENDA, HE
VOTES NO, NO, NO.
>> I DON'T MEAN TO BE COMICAL,